padam padam padam padam padam
bonjour tout le monde
je suis en pleine forme aujourd'hui et
je sens bon je ne me suis pas fumer avec
de l'eau de cologne à la fraise c'est
parfois comment refaire ma tante
adélaïde white je m'en suis ni sur la
tête un peu dans le dos et voilà j'ai
envie que tout le monde soit gay
aujourd'hui dans l'île aux enfants je
vais d'abord allé voir julie parce
qu'elle rit tout le temps
bonjour mademoiselle bonjour casimir
très occupé tu as vu comme je suis bon
très bon bah tu tu ne sens pas mon
parfum
quoi tient tante adélaïde m'a offert une
autre cologne
[Musique]
donc je sais rien non mais pourtant j'ai
mis près sur tout la bouteille écoute
casimir thuy adorable oui j'ai beaucoup
de travail tu vois alors je te suis plus
le moteur bing bon ben tant pis je te
laisse alors je vais aller voir françois
adam un bonjour françois comment vas tu
moi je vais très bien oui bonjour
casimir que s'il te plaît pas ce mois le
panneau qui est sur la chaise à côté du
doigt voilà merci tu as senti comme je
sens bon bah ma tante adélaïde m'a
offert une autre toile est parfumé à la
fraise des bois pour exception a désigné
alors 2 3 blancs 1 2 3 4 5 j'ai
l'impression souhaiteraient occuper un
oui oui c'est ça mais vous anime et
ballons rouges à bangkok des radars je
reviendrai tout à l'heure
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont tous les deux
mais alors tiendrait un facteur j'espère
que lui au moins aura un petit peu de
temps pour moi est important que nous
bonjour quasi mère je suis désolé je
suis très pressé je n'ai rien pour toi
je dis bonjour voilà votre paquet julie
merci je n'attendais pas mais ils sont
fous de travailler comme ça enfin haut
mais j'ai l'impression d'être
complètement inutile bon ce nouveau
casino bonjour monsieur du sna je suis
très content de pouvoir on vous avez
rendez vous avec une personne de qualité
ah non pas du tout est quoi le bien que
je le regrette forme il alors vous allez
pouvoir parler avec moi je m'ennuie mais
c'est totalement impossible casimir vous
refuser de parler avec moi ne pas du
tout ça avec un très grand plaisir vous
parlerez philosophie psychologie pas
tous le nom et au nom je voudrais
simplement que l'on parle de moi à oui
je vois et je le regrette casimir mais
j'ai rendez vous avec mon coiffeur
particulier pour me faire couper les
cheveux c'est un front alors mais qu'est
ce que je vais devenir mais tu peux
aller jouer avec françois mais non
françois travail julie travail j'ai
l'impression que je ne sers à rien ce
n'est pas grave casimir tu devrais
travailler toi aussi te rendre utile ah
oui c'est une idée mais mais mais
comment à jeter c'est conscience kazemi
râler à tout à l'heure mon bon casimir
bon et attendait le monsieur du snob
j'ai une idée oui qui attire j'ai une
idée combien vous prend votre coiffeur
pour vous couper les cheveux 100 francs
pour quoi bon reggae moi je voulais coup
pour 60 francs je suis d'accord mais
pour 50 francs pour 50 francs vous aurez
une coupe mais pas de shampooing ah bon
et bien 55 francs à 50 sec ce ne sera
pas la même coupe vous comprenez le prix
dépend du travail et dans votre cas vos
cheveux sont très sales abîmé kasei ya
beaucoup de travail pour moi alors je
suis d'accord pour 60 francs casimir
c'est entendu marché conclu sakho ne
bougez pas je vais chercher ma malle
magique ne t'inquiète pas je ne bougerai
non
bonjour monsieur du snob bonjour mon ami
mais oui tous voudront passer je vous
chercher partout j'avais une lettre à
vous remettre et comme je ne vous ai pas
trouvé je les laisse à la poste hamé est
très ennuyé ça on va écouter je dois
revenir ici apporter un kaka françois
oui alors si vous êtes encore là tout à
l'heure ben je vous apporterez votre
lettre à moins cher et 1000
vous êtes un être sensé que j'apprécie
de jour en jour un peu plus merci bien
monsieur du stop moi aussi vous savez je
vous apprécie bien tout à l'heure c'est
l'heure voilà me voilà monsieur du snav
bien nous allons pouvoir commencer très
bien je pose mon chapeau et makan je
vous en prie vous allez passer cette
blouse vous ne vous sentirez pas à merci
infiniment voisins voilà ça va ça va je
vous donne un tabouret
voilà mais attendez il y a un appui tête
qui va avec un appui-tête revoilà
bon
prenez également le peigne merci voilà
les ciseaux les ciseaux les six ans à
mais casey mears ce n'est pas une paire
de ciseaux
oh mais c'est vrai en excuser moi je me
suis trompé c'est le sécateur avec
lequel je coupe mes abo attendez je vais
le trouver
à mais ça non plus ça je sais où ça
c'est pour les cocistes demong lobby
bourgain abondante et
voilà a très bien
mehdi dont casimir je me pose une
question tout ça coûte oui est-ce que tu
s'est coupé les cheveux mais voyons
monsieur chris noth jomo les coupes à
moi même et tu n'as pas de cheveux ah
oui c'est vrai non mais je les coupe à
toute ma famille c'est mon père qui m'a
appris alors ah bon nous voilà rassurés
soyez tranquille
bon je vais vous
nous arranger tout ça
[Musique]
et voilà le cheddar va terminer
monsieur du snob vous allez être très
content monsieur du snob
mais ide ont
chuté
non mais quelle horreur
il est chaud
même tuer mais c'est à trappes mais que
s'est il passé si toi tu vas fait ça
ouais et alors et c'est monsieur de
snobs fait la demande et ouais alors il
voulait être chaud non mais comme
monsieur du snop est très snob j'ai
pensé qu'une coupe un peu original lui
plairait mais il va t'on sûr il
ne faut pas le réveiller trop vite
on vous croyez écoutez je j'ai quelque
chose pour arranger ça
voilà une périclite ouais
ça m'ira très bien je t'assure qu'il
sera très content
mais que se passe-t-il ici mais ces
messieurs l'islam que lui est il arrivé
les madones
tonné françois voilà votre paquet
mais didier jeu c'est clair pour
monsieur du snob -
c'est sûrement un rendez vous regardez
l'enveloppent alors s'il est un rendez
vous avec une personnalité importante
quelle catastrophe
au pardonnez moi mes chers amis je
m'étais endormi
mais qu'avez-vous à me regarder comme ça
y est il indiqué
figurez vous que j'ai rêvé que j'étais
choses
admirables
extraordinaire a quasiment c'est un
petit chez de très très venir chez du
snop voilà votre lettre à mes amis m'ont
donné voyons cela
oh la la
c'est la comtesse du ballet qui me
donnent rendez-vous quelle chance j'ai
pu me faire admirer avec ma nouvelle
coiffure très bien j'arrive bien je vous
l'activez famille j'ai bientôt les
attendait merci beaucoup merci
merci mme ineichen du club voilà les
émirs t 60 francs alors
du franc 20 francs 30 cran dans mon
bonbon 40 francs 50 francs 60 merci
monsieur du snav voilà les amis
reviennent
pour moi vous voyez comme un mars ma
coiffure lui plaît beaucoup oui il est
craint content et il le sera beaucoup
moins quand il s'apercevra qu'il a une
perruque il va être sérieux je ne
voudrais pas être là à ce moment là
bonjour tout le monde bonjour je viens
de croiser monsieur du snob j'en ris
encore figurez-vous qu'il s'est fait
teindre les cheveux en retz mais alors
rien de drôle à ces casimir qui lui a
mis une perruque après lui avoir coupé
tous ses cheveux mais quand monsieur
10,9 à découvrir ça il fera une colère
terrible europe on se met le plus tard
sur les lieux mais qu'il était derrière
ou
mais si la pyrrhus de monsieur du snob
misère
j'ai dû l'accrocher quand je les
croisais sur le chemin